yeah but let's jump to the story my
friends because none of it matters
none of it matters
it's happening from the new york post
nasa hired 24 theologians to study human
reaction to aliens
the official narrative i guess or not
official narrative but what people are
saying is basically that nasa is trying
to figure out how different people of
different faith backgrounds will react
to the knowledge of intelligent alien
life in our uh existing
the first thing i'll say is
it's strange to me that there are people
who believe aliens don't exist
in this massive of a universe as big as
it is
there's got to be life somewhere you
know what i mean now whether or not i
can travel the universe and come here
and interact that's a different story
the new york post reports between heaven
and earth where do aliens fit in that's
the question nasa hopes theologians at
the center for a theological inquiry in
prince new jersey can answer university
of cambridge religious scholar reverend
dr andrew davison who also holds a
doctorate in biochemistry from oxford is
one of the 24 theologians enlisted to
help his upcoming book astrobiology and
christian doctrine do it due out in 2022
will cover in part of the cti and nasa's
joint spiritual exploration
there's a question
is it really happening you know who
really
you know who really gets credit and all
this scientologists they've had this
right all along they believe that aliens
came down and the church of scientology
wins
oh yeah there's aliens absolutely and um
well whether they came down or not but
literally like what was it in 2020
they're like the government's like dude
there's ufos and we don't know what they
are yeah people are like man and the
only one i saw really getting uh like
through like if i was a kid like and you
told me that aliens and the loch ness
monster were real and bigfoot i'd have
been the mo i'd be running around the
block naked telling everybody about it
right like now it's like joe rogan was
the only one like dude there's aliens
and that was it and nobody cared well
there's absolutely alien or ufos when
you have the government promoting the
idea of of aliens and neil de grise
tyson i just automatically think that
they're preparing for the next psy up i
mean the corporate media the government
aliens aliens it used to be just people
outside of the box talking about this
but now it's the establishment saying
there's aliens out there there's
something out there that defies the laws
of science that buys the laws of physics
we don't know what it is um that's
absolutely mind-boggling so is neil
degrasse titan uh tyson now a part of
the establishment i think so absolutely
he's completely changed his tune from he
he's a g that dude's smart yeah i think
he's getting paid
have you have you guys ever read
watchmen the graphic novel i have not so
it's different from the movie and the
graphic novel is more relevant in this
regard in uh in watchmen the bad guy
simulates an alien attack to force
global unity because it's the height of
the cold war and russia and the us are
going to file missiles at each other and
nukes and so he stages an alien invasion
convinces everybody we have to unify to
fight against it to stop war right
maybe that's the sight
convince everybody of the world that we
need one world government because of an
alien invasion you ever see independence
day i was just about to bring up i think
they did this movie the will smith
before right so independence day is
all the different countries are trying
to they're all independently fighting
these aliens and then they're like
send out the word you know here's how
you take them out or whatever we're
gonna do a virus in the sequel they did
the whole planet is a unified it's one
world government unified military moon
military base in case the aliens come
that i think
is is a lot of people thought covert
would do this that this this this you
know universal threat would we unite
everybody i'm not convinced i think if
they actually did discover aliens the
left and the right would react and hate
each other over it and it would become
another tribal issue well we have to
explain why the government for decades
and decades was like aliens don't exist
you're crazy you're you're a conspiracy
theorist you're out of your mind if you
do and then they just officially change
their stance like oh yeah they exist
they're out there why what was behind
this larger stance that that that
essentially was 180 degrees in the
opposite direction so obviously a lot of
people have those questions did you hear
alex jones recently
when he went on that he went on that
rant and uh uh and like i was like i
can't do it anymore he's like i'm gonna
i'm gonna go to pre-record and just
leave and he was saying he just started
yelling and he was like an alien
intelligence just running this show or
whatever
and i'm like okay look
you know part of his rant was that he
was mad people weren't standing up to
tyranny but then he mentioned like alien
intelligence controlling everything and
i'm like okay now you lost me
yeah alex jones has uh
but like it's it's funny because then we
get this story about nasa hiring
theologians there's an episode of star
trek the next generation
where uh picard and the gen and the
enterprise crew are making first contact
in star trek the next generation the
federation only contacts
civilizations once they discover warp
technology because it means they're
about to start traveling the stars and
go to other planets and they'll soon be
interacting with life in the universe so
they come to this planet where they just
invent war
and they're like you need to consider
what this will mean for your people and
your planet and the president of the
country they go to basically says we're
a deeply religious people
this is too much for us too soon people
would lose their minds if they
discovered this hence the new york post
talking about theologians and needing to
better understand this because i think a
lot of people might lose their minds if
aliens were here
then the assumption is
aliens are here they are involved and
everything that's happening is related
to some like alien contact or something
we just don't know it yet well here's
the thing the government can literally
say the opposite thing of what they said
yesterday and people believe it falsely
literally came out and said you don't
need to wear masks don't need to wear
them they just get dirty and then he's
like schmutz we're like three of them
and people like yes science all the
government has to do is say aliens
science and people be like oh
oh they will forget people are dumb like
the twitter generation i say this
because it's like there's no history
like it's the news cycle is like one
minute people have no short-term memory
it's like they smoke too much wheat
people are just they don't remember
anything and this is long term like area
fifth was area 5700 heinz 57 which is
area 55
mine's 57. it's delicious but anyways
can you tell i'm hungry so
so at the end of the day i think that
people don't know
about that whole alien thing like my
generation was all about aliens aliens
was my like i'm like i read books on
aliens and i was like going to the
library remember libraries we had those
before
i went to library i'd check out these
books on aliens these kids don't
remember that like for example my
wrestling team we're at a tournament i'm
like dude beat that kid up like hulk
hogan like who's hall coke and i'm like
you don't know how kogan is they have no
idea about the alien stuff that went on
it'll be dudes like us who are too old
to care like i'm 41 i think a crazy 41
year old talking about aliens gonna get
anybody excited when they were talking
about ufos and no one really cared i was
like that's kind of it right yeah
they're going to keep trickling out
stories like this to desensitize people
and then in like two or three years if
if they're really aliens i'm not saying
there are they'll have to slow roll it
and then eventually one day they'll be
like oh we saw a spaceship no no no no
no sorry sorry go ahead finish no that's
basically eventually they'd be like hey
this is bborp he's really the one
running there's calling the shots here
he was really under president biden's
skin
trump's gonna be like was the greatest
president ever everyone agrees at least
that's what i was told if you don't
believe in aliens i just want you to
look up the name lori lightfoot
that is a specimen right there you look
at what's going on and i think a lot of
people want to believe in aliens because
you look at the seemingly coordinated
effort that's been happening around the
country some people think it's you know
the illuminati or whatever but alex
jones was yelling there's like an alien
intelligence controlling all the stuff
and i'm like yo i don't know about any
of that stuff because it would mean that
like ron desantis isn't working with the
aliens or something so there's no
coordinated alien i don't know man
there's a lot that the government knows
that they're not releasing that they're
not getting out there to the general
public that still is classified which is
ridiculous i mean we should at least
know what's going on but we should also
be prepared for a potential psyop and
for them to weaponize and use that
information for their own benefit and
their larger power it's a great
distraction right there's no evidence
we've got aliens coming to earth we
there's there's very much paradoxes a
lot of speculation about it but i think
it's
it's funny to see these stories
it's fun to talk about absurdity at
least at least
aliens are in the realm of possibility
unlike don lemon asking about whether or
not an airliner was sucked into a black
hole
could there be aliens yes astronomically
abysmal odds that anything like this is
ever you know i'll tell you what's
infinitely more infinitely more likely
is that the government needs
distractions yes they need the people to
get whipped up in a frenzy if aliens
ever came the first thing i think is
like is that a government projection of
a vehicle is it a drone are they just
trying to screw with us because i look
until i see beat bort come out and then
walk up to me and go rock i'm going to
be like i don't believe it i don't
believe it i'll never believe it
until i see beat borb himself yeah i'm a
whole
so the aliens working with the lizard
people that's the question the aliens
are the lizard people no no the lizard
people are from hollow earth oh okay or
something yeah isn't that stranger
things i'm so confused no
there's there's i i i love these you
know deep dive rabbit hole websites i
was reading one that claims there was a
very intelligent species of dinosaur
that fled into caves when you know the
the extinction event happened and
survived and they've been evolving for
you know millions of years so they're
substantially more advanced than humans
and their underground cities and there
are people who believe that stuff man
they believe they're underground cities
of futuristic aliens you know not i'm
sorry they're they're terrestrial but
like lizard people or whatever it's it's
crazy what was it oh yeah i was watching
the simpsons there's a clip
when um bob dole and bill clinton are
king and kodos
and then homer simpson's like your your
politicians are actually green space
lizards and i was like is that where the
conspiracy came from or were they making
fun of the conspiracy because it was
like pre-internet you know a long time
ago
a long time ago like the simpsons have
gotten more things correct
oh yeah that's true
of all the things to get right it's
going to turn out that politicians are
actually alien lizards i i'm not dude
like here's the thing about 2020 and
2021 nothing surprises me anymore like i
used to be like i can't believe that and
i'm like okay cool it's thursday you
know
you just you see the most absurd things
happen people say the most absurd things
and it just happens and you're like oh
it's just normal now
there's a super chat here by julie
simone that is uh relevant to the
argument we had about the yellow fever
single shot dose
saying that according to the cdc it is
just a single dose i went to a doctor
and he said it's a subcutaneous
injection and you have to come back
after six months and that if you get the
second shot after six months it uh
provides immunity for ten years
that's what i was told when i went to
the doctor but not every six months
no no no it's you get the shot then you
come back for a six a booster at six
months and then it's good for ten years
at least that's what i was told yeah
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time